you and I were kinda in the same thing
with Trump which was that I was
thoroughly enjoying seeing the the elite
and the media and all of these [ __ ]
artists and these Talking Heads that
just talk and don't have anything really
to say a huge amount yeah they all get
paid a ton of money of course far more
than we're making on YouTube I assure
you but all but all of the power all of
the money all of this stuff they lost
and the night of the election I was on
with Andrew clave and I'm not sure if
you know him but he said I do yeah
he's a very funny guy great guy he's a
great guy yeah and he said he's a
hardcore conservative I just had him on
the show a couple weeks ago but he said
something that I thought was just
spectacular that night he said look all
of the elites all the power all the
money all the media all everybody wanted
help Hillary to win Trump won and what
that shows you is that the power of the
people in this country is still so
powerful that it's it's the most
important thing that we have that
everyone worldwide pretty much in every
country in the world would be jealous of
what we had and and here it is we have
it so so my question for you really is
that you saw this coming too and I saw
you were getting a lot of [ __ ] people
were saying did you know sporty truck I
didn't think it was gonna happen I like
like with brexit I thought it would be
close I thought it'd be I thought being
the narrowest of narrow margins you know
and I thought that it would be a good a
good sort of smack to the face and give
them a wake-up call okay right we've got
to start thinking about changing but I
mean this is actually better because now
they've lost so now they have no choice
but to have some sort of introspection
that's sorry I interrupted
well no no I'll go from there do you
think they're having introspection
because I don't sense it I there were a
couple days where I thought maybe they
were going to and I saw a piece in The
New York Times saying the Liberals have
to rethink themselves and something in
New York magazine so a couple of the
elite elite said yeah we have to think
about it but on the ground and in terms
of the usual cast of characters that are
leading this thing I don't see any
introspection I see doubling down on
racism and bigotry
I see doubling down on silencing people
and screaming over everybody are you
seeing it maybe you're seeing it and I'm
not oh it
it is everywhere it absolutely is
everywhere and the more sort of radical
leftist um I don't come journalist so
I'm just gonna call them bloggers and
I'm gonna call them bloggers because
most of they most their journalism comes
from Twitter I'm so tired of Donald
Trump's Twitter accounts being news yeah
don't you get off your fat asses anymore
and actually go in the investigator but
it's a lot easier to get your fun yeah
way easier um sorry I just got
straighter what's question you know well
they don't even give you a chance they
don't even give you a chance to be
outraged anymore because they're sitting
there monitoring his Twitter feed so
that they can get outreach to tell you
that you're outraged yeah that's uh no
you're right there has been an awful lot
of doubling down when Bernie Sanders
came out against identity politics that
was an important thing and I think that
a lot of Bernie supporters didn't know
how to take that and that I think spun
the Atlantic in the New York Times that
read pieces the criticized identity
politics saying we're going to have to
move beyond this yeah yeah they've
identified the problem but the you're
right the backlash is terrible I mean
I've seen and again these are mainstream
media articles and like you know the
Guardian the independent places like
this where they are just ridiculing the
concept saying that this is this is like
um the eternal howl of the white man or
something like this is just like you're
[ __ ] idiots you don't even understand
you know it's the fact that you
constantly play this game of divide and
conquer and it's just you've lost you
know you've just you've conquered a tiny
irrelevant area of the internet and
people aren't paying attention if you
look at the numbers across the board
they're just sliding down everyone's
getting sick of the crap and yeah you
know our numbers just keep going up and
they won't listen
they just won't listen so that's it
that's a perfect segue for what I think
the meat of what we can talk about here
is in case we haven't got to the beat
yet which is that we're online media
people you know I don't necessarily
consider myself a journalist in that I'm
not out in the field doing journalism I
yeah I I talked to people I interview
people I share my thoughts on things
whatever you want to call that that's
fine
but I think one of the things that
really the narratives that really got
constructed over the course this
election is that we know that mainstream
media has been crumbling forever they're
purging they're know
nobody trusts them anymore they've all
gone partisan blah blah blah and the
online people that have been doing this
for a few years our numbers are all goin
up people are paying attention to us
more than they trust us more all that
stuff and I think it got to perfect
parity and now we're starting to win and
I'm curious I'm curious do you think
that they are gonna come down on us and
this can also sort of segue into some of
this YouTube censorship stuff and what's
going on on Twitter and the rest of it I
mean they have a lot of money and a lot
of power still and you know we're on a
webcam and Google hangout at the moment
uh-huh so we think that all Oh God who
knows um I think they will do I mean we
are when when you take a man's
livelihood and the source of his income
then he's going to do everything he can
to protect that and not take aim at
anyone they will do everything that you
only met men I know you made a white
heterosexual cisgender man that's not
even black man not not Asian men just
the white men um so yeah they will do
everything in their power but thankfully
the power is actually quite limited they
don't have control over YouTube for
example I mean like if I if I do a video
and use them a few clips from say The
Guardian or I actually did that one
regarding Trevor Noah with Viacom I got
a copyright strike on it immediately and
I won it within a day or two YouTube
came down on my side saying that this is
fair use and he can do this and belief
you Viacom so you know it's youtuber
it's under pressure from these sort of
activists but it's not it's not as bad
as people think it's just it could be as
bad as people think and I'm not saying
that it won't become bad in the future
in might but at the moment it's not that
bad
it's just that there are kind of storm
clouds on the horizon but I don't think
they I don't think it's the mainstream
media that we have the power to do this
anymore
it was honestly I think the the I think
when like historians look back at this
they'll look back and it'll be what was
it was the New York Times who issued the
apology that they had become
cheerleaders not journalists and they
were read dedicating themselves to
honest reporting
by doing so implicitly saying everything
they've done before would you solve it
and it's just like I mean I appreciate
the sentiment but you understand how
awful it seems that you have to do that
you know and and I guess its power but
had gone to their head or something
you know ideological conformity had gone
to their head and I don't but it's kind
of a beautiful thing don't you don't you
think it's a beautiful thing sort of
watching it watching it crumble and also
that that all of these people it's like
they have all these read all the cable
news people and all of the big media
company but they have all this money all
these resources and it's like well don't
care anymore you had your chance and you
screwed up you know and by no means am i
saying that I'm perfect or that you're
perfect and and by the way the the whole
idea of online media it raises a whole
other set of problems because anyone can
do this so the bar of entry is so low so
so how do you figure out who you trust
cuz I'm really struggling with that and
people ask me that all the time and it's
like even when I'm reading articles I'm
like man I got to read five articles
about the same thing just to piece them
together to figure out what might
actually about it that's actually what I
do to its credit that want the the one
thing that the mainstream media is
actually good at is reporting facts if
they want to that's a backhanded
compliment if I ever heard one it's an
it just because the the greatest the
greatest crime of the mainstream media
is lies by omission everyone knows
everyone knows if you go to the Guardian
you're gonna get half the story if you
go to the Daily Mail or whatever right
with Fox News you're getting a half the
story you to get a more comprehensive
view you actually do have to like say
read five articles from different
sources to make sure that you know that
and you will find very specific not
necessarily not necessarily I don't know
I don't call them open lies because I
don't I don't even know if these people
know that they're doing what they're
doing because I think a lot of these
people are so partisan by this point
that they don't really understand what
they're doing is dishonest I think they
just think that well you know I mean
like the number of times I hear
something go well that's that's
right-wing or they'll say or they're
just doing it for money it's like okay
they aren't refutations their dealer
just amazing tactics you know if you can
tell me how it's wrong then I'm all ears
but if you're just gonna go while I
don't like it because of the source then
you've not disproven anything and I'm
going to treat it as valid until you can
you know especially if I can't find it
obviously so yeah it's it's tough and
it's get it's gonna get more difficult
especially as the arming of the fake
news thing really drives me crazy
the irony is is quite delicious I have
to say and the the problem is they have
a point there is a lot going around on
the internet that is just flat-out
nonsense and it gets me you know often
millions of views and people share it
people think it's true and it's one of
the simply you've just got to be
discerning you just have to understand
the landscape and what is likely to
happen from the context of what has
already previously happened and who is
reporting what's to you most people
aren't that informed like most people
just don't have the time to be that
informed I mean they've got jobs and a
family's got lights the Amish they
expect to read a newspaper and even if
they don't even if they don't say look
we're gonna we're gonna give you know
equal time to you know like the the
alt-right as we do to the sjw's you at
least expect some sort of distance from
one's own biases and emotions when
they're writing the piece but
unfortunately that's just something they
don't do and so you have to go out of
your way and it's rare than what I tell
my favorite articles are the ones that
are actually written from an objective
standpoint well and at the end I don't
even mind if they say well yeah and we
think that this or I think this or
whatever but just give me the facts
without trying to put a spin on it for
the love of God well it's just
incredible to me that the [ __ ] news
that we've all been calling out is now
calling everything else fate news and
when I say that I fully acknowledge that
your your point stand which is that
there is a lot of there's a lot of
nonsense out there in fakery but just to
show you how there is something going on
here that's kind of bigger than us like
doesn't it seem pretty obvious to you
that there was somehow I don't know who
is
and I'm not a conspiracy theorist so I
would always say extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence as Carl
Sagan said but sorry Glenn big funds
yeah it's a gate thing people keep
asking me why don't talk about it
because there's no evidence you know
ever everything you're seeing is
conjecture and and I'm wrong I would
never let Joe Biden near any of my
children there's some of those videos
were Biden and the kids are really gross
disgusting isn't it it's I mean just no
does he think he's doing oh but anyway
so I'm Kerry but your point of pizza
gate actually stands because I feel the
same way a lot of people keep tweeting
it at me saying why are you talking
about this and it's like I can't even
garner the slightest bit of what's
really happening here so I'll wait and
if something is proven that of course
I'll talk about it but my point was that
this meme of fake news now that all the
mainstream media is saying and
everything is fake shows me that somehow
there's some coordination somewhere I
don't know what that means exactly I'm
not saying it's a bunch of guys at a
table yeah that's and that's actually
much worrying part right is I think that
it's actually um so in gamergate when
gaming it was happening what we saw from
the media was something that they called
a cascade effect Owens a good term
because I think it makes a lot of sense
so basically a fourth leader in their
community someone who you know everyone
else tends to follow would put out an
article and then I mean you know a lot
of their columns now like five
paragraphs long so take half an hour to
knock this up that basically says the
same thing and then you slap it up on
your own website and then everyone's
that's a good point right and then it
just propagates it doesn't need to have
any kind of organization because they're
all basically taking cues from one
another and go yeah okay we're all in
the same team great because that is how
they operate I mean we saw like with
them as reclines journalists they they
do operate as a faction these outlets
are meant to be in competition with each
other and yet they're conspiring
together and they they actually do it
like with malice intent malicious intent
as well so it's just one of the center
it's just like okay I mean and this
isn't just like nonsense to me we can
name the people on the list
you know it was only tennis and the same
with the emails from Hillary Clinton you
know these things they do actually
happen and I tell you I've got some
advice for a conspiracy theorist because
I I love a good conspiracy I look I love
conspiracies but you you if you can't
name the vais you can't report as fact
you don't know it's true if you can't
name them by name it's nonsense and so
that's the that's the important thing so
like John Podesta Tony Podesta you know
Biden or if there's any hard evidence
connecting them then yeah that's
something but to say like you know the
new world or they want to poison
efficient and the frogs gay or something
that's nonsense
you know they who you know it's too it's
too broad as to nonsense it doesn't mean
anything
well I like I like sort of the the
direction there because you're basically
saying that it's the group think that's
doing it's not a group of thinkers a
group of thinkers but it's actually
groupthink they all taking these cues
from each other and and going with this
stuff so look we're we're starting to
win which i think is nice but but this
now will bring us back to where we
started and it combines both of these
things the fight that that you and I are
trying to do here and really save the
left if if it can be saved
do you think do you think that we really
can win because I'll go depressing for
just a second and then I'll answer is
that might might fear at this point is
this thing has gotten so out of control
and now because of Trump because of what
they what they view him to be whether he
is or not but he's such a good bad guy
for them that there's almost nothing
that we can say within the rational part
of their brain that's gonna work so for
example if I say you know what you guys
were really against money in politics
Hillary had all the money
Trump won so that's good Trump isn't a
Christian conservative everyone knows he
doesn't care about gay marriage and weed
and an abortion is you know like the
Republicans that one of the things that
hammer advised he's not real
conservative is that yes I know everyone
knows he's he's the whole Trump he's not
really you know I don't think I'll Trump
casma lots of the things that both sides
care about I really think he doesn't
care at all
so what do you what do you think about
the idea that so I've been pushing this
idea or at least talking about this idea
that I think as a populist of course
there's danger with the populist Hitler
was a populist so of course there is
danger so but that was someone like him
he's not an ideologue in that he's not
Mike Pence who's got what you know would
take his Christian conservative views to
govern with that we might as a
population we might be able to push him
to do some good stuff yeah if we can
kind of agree on what good stuff is
because he wants to be liked
do you think that's a fair way i I made
exactly this point when I I did an
interview for a channel called er none
of the above
and I made that exact point it's a
Donald Trump he is either even if it's
even if he because he's a narcissist I
mean he wants to hear you saying Trump
Trump Trump so just tell him what you
want you know make it obvious to him
either mass tweet at him he obviously
pays attention to what goes on on
Twitter so if he gets 10,000 tweets in
an hour of people going you know don't
sign the TPP or whatever the issue is
and he's already killed that hasn't he
he's already killed the TPP he's already
saved a bunch of jobs everyone's
complaining about him like anything but
he's actually got quite a lot done
before he's even a seeing the office so
he might not be that bad
he might just have been and they're
playing the crowd or something look at
some with regards to the left though um
the social justice warriors themselves
the the ideologue activists who are
doing this because they think it makes
them good people will never change their
mind will never change their mind they
they will they will
they're totally indoctrinated into this
ideology and they won't change and they
don't want to they and it's this is this
is why the whole world's view is
basically on phosphide because if you
say right okay well I have um I have a
suggestion they'll say yes but you're a
white man you would say that and that
just diffuses everything you've ever say
it's like okay well I guess it is coming
from a white man you know and if that is
enough to be legitimized me then I mean
we literally have nothing to say to each
other and thankfully that's a very
unpopular position with any race really
any gender most people aren't on board
with this so this is why the loss but
when it comes to reforming my left we
have to we have to make these people
understand that they are the
fundamentalist Christians there are the
flat-earthers of the left these people
have lost
they have lost badly they have they held
the reins of power for about eight years
under Barack Obama and look how it's
ended you've got brexit you've got Trump
the Pens coming up it's only just lost
their bloody referendum I haven't even
looked into yet but Myrtle earnest
Merkel just ban the burqa today I mean
yeah Merkel's arguing for values like
son look whatever your whatever you
think about your own ideology it's a
practically failure it hasn't worked
it's turned people against you and now
you are the most hated people in society
you know people hate you more than they
hate the fundamentalist Christians and
they used to hate the fundamentalist
Christians and so you in the marketplace
of ideas your your ideas were deemed
wanting and they have failed so if they
ever come to you and say well this is
right I don't care what you say you're
wrong to argue that position we know
that position has been discredited it's
it's absolutely nonsense so what needs
to happen is a root and branch
ideological reform the left where people
have to get back to these fundamental
principles and why that they're on the
Left what is it they think they're
advocating for because you know these I
saw this field day
20-25 percent of homeless people are
women in the papers up it is not a good
thing
isn't that like hardly any of them that
was the problem we need to solve solve
the homeless women problem okay
so 75% the homeless are okay that's an
acceptable number it's just the 25 this
is the problem that enters politics
though there is no benefits to being a
man when you're homeless you know very
marginal benefit if anything and being
homeless is a much heavier burden for
you know anyone to bet to bear so we the
fact that they're women it doesn't
matter the fact that we the fact we're
homeless is the problem so we need to
start focally transition from identity
politics to issue politics so what's the
problem like homelessness right does it
matter whose houses no it doesn't it
matters that anyone's home so what do we
need to write we need to get whatever
shelters get housing programs get them
off the streets get them in some sort of
rehabilitation schemes get them to
become productive members of society
again which I'm sure they want as well
you know
I speak to homeless people sometimes
because I actually I never get to
charity I I don't trust any of these big
charities but I do give change to
homeless people when I passed industry
so I always looking at I don't think if
that were me my god I would just love it
if someone gave me a better change and
well I really hate this often nefarious
or myth oh they just spent on drugs okay
the dudes homeless i if I had some drugs
I'd give them to him myself you know
this dude lives on the street and begs
for food and you're worried about like
going most fun you know and and so I
like to see when the money's going I
like to know that someone who actually
needs is getting it I I'm not I would
never ever recommend giving money to
like the Clinton fan base by the
Cleveland foundation last I saw I think
about a week ago their their donations
were down something around 40% which
just proves what the point what is the
whole time they were doing such great
work and all of their people all of
their donors were doing in general it
was so great well then of course you
keep giving the donations but it wasn't
about that it was about access and now
that she will have less influence you
will get less access it's like it all
all of the stuff just kind of crumbled
at once but I like what you're saying I
like what you're saying about the issues
idea and that's how we could win because
we can't win on breaking the people that
are that this is the danger of calling
everyone racist it's so hard to break
out of that if you accuse someone of
being the scum of the earth for three
years
absolutely and no I mean I mean a lot of
people I'm gonna want to listen so like
the sjw types who spout this cause the
Marilyn I mean if you can go to any any
online newspaper and look at the
comments on these sjw articles people
are just angry people pushing back they
have been for a while and they should
have seen it coming they should have
seen the popular discontent and I again
I I hate this kind of collective guilt
individual responsibility dichotomy they
want forum they are you know we just
just cuz we said this is the thing that
you know it's like no you're all saying
this you're all don't you have to
understand that the public if you wanna
stalking groups and generalizations and
the public is seeing this wall of hate
coming from the left-wing media
the left-wing media is is populist it's
arrogant it's everywhere and for some
reason people think giving keep giving
credence especially with their op-eds I
just can't understand what anyone reads
them but for some reason they do um say
that basically these people they have to
be I mean literally everyone when they
taught them Afghan oh you lost you're
wrong
you know I and I blood yeah but I've got
all these all these fancy justifications
well it doesn't matter even if I don't
know how they're wrong
well you failed I mean you you can't
appeal to voters with it therefore you
can never win the power back therefore
you can never in you know get any of
these things done therefore you've lost
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
you say even if what you're saying was
brilliant and it's not it's [ __ ]
what you're saying is brilliant it
doesn't matter it just doesn't work
it's like communism it's just not going
to work it's a great force people isn't
never gonna work for human beings and so
this is the same thing it's it it's just
not possible so I I want them to
understand they have to change and if
they're not prepared to change then they
can't be part of the conversation I'm
sorry saying it but you you are a these
people are a drag
they hold the left I mean they are the
reason the rest of the left has lost so
yeah we definitely transitioned from
identity politics to issue politics and
we need to understand why we care about
these things why go back to the the root
principles of liberalism what it was
designed for and why and the just the
five sort of principles that are the
pillars of Western civilization were
there for a reason
you know though people look up to those
things for a reason I mean and I I don't
want to sound like a Western chauvinist
but I am there isn't a better system and
if you can show really good it's pretty
good the West
exactly exactly it's this a thing right
no oh if Donald Trump Madonna Trump wins
I'm gonna move the counter know who
moved to Mexico hey shut up oh you don't
want to why is that you know don't even
get any move to Saudi Arabia though is
Canada that's for God people you don't
go there okay Lena Dunham did not move
further and of course they didn't know
them did the full of [ __ ] I can't
understand why anyone listens to
celebrities on anything I mean in
ancient Rome actors and musicians were
considered lower about the same social
level as prostitutes
and for what they could add to society
and so I really started I think maybe
should go back to that kind of mindset
again when George cleaning says all we
need to take loads of refugees routes go
okay George how many are you taking you
know that's very noble but these people
obviously don't live anywhere near any
of the things that going on they don't
care they're not interested they just
want 230 signal and feel good about
themselves and I'm sick of it and I'm
sure a lot of other people are sick
there and yeah suck it I don't care I
was I was on a radio show a progressive
radio show maybe eight months or so ago
and the guy was being incredibly hostile
to me even though it was an old friend
of mine actually was being really
hostile to me and I was not being
hostile and he would we started talking
about immigration and I said look I
don't know what our vetting is it's
impossible to know what's going on it's
clear look what's happening at the
borders in in Europe like we have to
figure out what's going on here and he
kept trying to imply that I was somehow
being bigoted or racist or something
like that and then I said to him I was
like you know if you're so for
immigration you make a lot more money
than me I know roughly how much you make
and you work at a big media company why
don't you you know maybe taking a couple
immigrants take a couple migrants into
your house and then suddenly you you
freaked out it's like no if you show
these people that this is not just
theory you can't just have your [ __ ] in
theory you have to have it in practice
too they crumble pretty quick absolutely
they plan never I mean one of the
reasons that some the the people who you
are are getting to the point when they
understand is aid the the way the votes
and the polls have been going recently
but some EU officials daughter was
murdered by a migrant the other day and
it's just okay well now you know how
everyone else is feeling you know like
it all object you could find a map and I
sentence you after this where they it's
basically I'm on Google a live map of
just all of the crimes that have been
done by migrants in Germany and it's
it's just it's the whole country and
it's thick with just you know you got
things and it's just constant dots
everywhere this is like my god I mean
the the German figures were leaked from
the German police in 2016 wasn't 26 in
2015 I think was actually
400,000 crimes were committed by these
migrants and I mean you know most of
them are petty crimes but thefts and
muggings and stuff like that it's not
like life-ending
but there are still thousands of people
who have been raped have been murdered
and it's just it's just I'm not really
you didn't vet these people at all you
don't know who they are you don't know
why they've come and I've had people
from Syria comments from my videos going
I know people have gone that they've
just gone for the money they've just
gone because they know that the Germans
will put them in a refugee camp and give
them money each month and then as soon
as they stop giving money middle you
mean like when they the Danish
government said that they weren't going
to give benefits to migrants only four
thousand of them left oh really
okay well there we go it's not there was
a war it's that you thought you mean it
some free money and they and the thing
is it drives me crazy the whole sort I
mean what did you think was gonna happen
you know yeah yeah you can all come
we've got Mike I mean obviously that's
gonna incentivize people who aren't
actually there for the real reason you
know it's obviously going to do that and
then I've heard like plans of Oh what we
can do is I'm going to pay them to go
home it's like no no that's [ __ ] we
know that doesn't work because of the
Vikings that's exactly what the French
and English kings did and what happened
Oh more Vikings came because they went
back with a ton of treasure and gone
yeah this thing's gave it to us you know
it just it just incentivizes people to
come you unfortunately you just you're
gonna have to do it effectively what
Eastern Europe is doing just say no you
know the answer's no go away you go to
China ask them you know go to Iran ask
them are they gonna say no as well
although you know it's I I don't want
that heartless but there are so many
problems that have come along with this
and it's been so it nobody apart from
the political elite have had any input
in any of this
they haven't had Merc Merkel has been
under such pressure not to do this and
yet she did it anyway
almost like an article of faith you know
when when you see a tall man she would
be talking about it almost as if this
was some kind of religious duty that she
was doing and it's okay that's dangerous
you know right and she she did her
religious duty and and what happened a
million and a half people came in the
system is under strain the crime that
you just mentioned and then as of the
time they were taping us today she's
proposing this burqa man so it's like
this
hell yeah I really trust you to get that
sword Merkel yeah oh yeah yeah I trust
that you're gonna be the one to do all
this you know
forgive me if I'm cynical here but it's
not that I mean ultimately this
lightning crisis might be the result of
might might end up with you breaking up
which in my opinion is a good thing but
I mean surely they're not all looking at
the haven't that's a great thing
themselves they must be furious but um
Leo began game back to the the the
reform of the left so I really think
this is the most important thing for
left-leaning people to talk about it is
to understand how social justice works
why it thinks what it thinks and then to
identify the people who are pushing it
and tell them they have to change or
they have to leave because they do they
absolutely do they they just cannot be
any room for this kind of bigotry and
that's what it is you know to say well
it's because you're White's that that is
a generalization based on race that is
the thing you complain about when it
happens to black people I don't care
what your systems of oppression say on
an individual level that's an
unacceptable thing to do even if you
think it's just Pheidon and they do and
that's why I like your friend like you
saying he was getting used being really
hostile to you when you were being
polite there's no excuse for them but
they think they're acting in service of
a greater good and and that's one of the
things I think there are some nice like
elementary concepts that these people
forgot I mean the greater good or the
common well the common good is for
everyone the greater good is for a
certain section of people and almost I
mean I can't think of an ideology in the
20th century that didn't butcher people
that didn't also have a greater good in
mind when they were butchering people
and then Fidel Castro dies and you see
Trudeau like oh my hero dude he had
firing squads just execution squads this
guy was a monster I can't believe it you
know
yeah everything's kind of backwards you
know it all sort of leads me to I think
where we should probably end this for
today although next time we're gonna get
you in the States finally we're gonna do
this like I said mobile but that for
people with flexible Minds because I
think that's the through line here is
that as a
Oh liberal as what a liberal is supposed
to be I think we have flexible minds I'm
pretty sure that there's no information
if I could prove to you was true that
you would you might not like it at first
you might try to argue against it but if
I consistently prove something to be
true that you would eventually come
around and that's what a flexible mind
is all about not being beholden to an
ideology but me national but being
rational being beholden to the truth and
we seem to live in a time that
everyone's using this phrase post truth
now where everyone just kind of makes up
their own truth but we live in a time
where it's like the loudest people are
screaming and the loudest people are
getting the most retweets and the most
views and all the clickbait and all that
stuff where it's for people like us and
I think for the people that like that
are watching this right now that like
the stuff that we're doing and we're
putting out there it makes our job a
little harder because having a flexible
mind also means I think I want to live a
pretty decent life too I want to not
devote every bit of energy that I have
to to fighting with people and all that
stuff and and not being not becoming a
demagogue that I would hate at the same
time and there so basically amazingly I
just view this as our job is a little
harder because being rational in an
irrational world is a little harder I I
think that our job is made more
difficult than everyone else's job by
the fact that we don't have an identity
that's the problem and I mean like but
you've been arguing against identity
politics awesome I know I have I know I
know I don't I'm not suggesting that
identity is a panacea for anything but
there's the olds right became a really
powerful force but if you look at it the
opera is tiny the author it's really
small I mean they're like the biggest
outright bloggers have got like thirty
forty thousand subscribers you know
that's a tiny movement and yet they were
just dedicated and noisy online they
caused a lot of trouble and suddenly
Hillary Clinton isn't legitimizing them
in her speech it's like oh my god that's
suck this shitposting has gone from the
Internet to Hillary Clinton's mouth
where she's denouncing a cartoon frog
she's literally reading Milos Breitbart
articles and and by the way Milo isn't
even considered all right
you of course he just likes them because
they're fun well that's the irony
everything has been flipped on its head
right now there's such self-righteous
drivel coming out of the left right now
that nothing's funny The Daily Show is
not funny the what's-her-name that has
that TBS show I keep watching these
commercials it's like it's not funny
you're all lecturers and actually the
stuff that is funny I don't like I don't
like the swastika I don't I don't like
Nazis but the stuff that's coming out of
the right is actually the subversive
stuff now comedy is supposed to be
subversive it's supposed to me against
the power and the left is just sucking
up to the Machine absolutely the left
have been pontificating for years it's
exactly the same you know The Daily Show
and Samantha bee oh that's the one I was
thinking of I mean ah it's appallingly
horrible it's just not funny you're not
Fillion that's all
so stop please guys you know oh yeah
that's the thing they've got the they've
got a narrative they want to project and
they can't mock their own narrative you
know and they're the ones trying to set
like a normative no this is how it
should be and it's like well no it
shouldn't
it's nonsense and these guys are just
mocking you relentlessly I mean the
thing with the facts that's I totally
agree there isn't that then there should
be no facts that are forbidden and
that's again I mean that is probably one
of the key crutches of the left for
example like that there is no denying
that black people on average have a
lower distribution of IQ than some other
race like white people in Asians right
there's no doubting that but what drives
me I mean that scientific fact but what
drives me crazy about the odds right is
going to go right so now we can do some
ice and then we can no we can't we don't
penalize people for having a low IQ at
all and you're not trying to do anything
about the white people with low IQ so
that just means you're targeting black
people because they're black you don't
care about the IQ at all that's just a
convenient foil we're not going to do
anything to any of these people based on
their IQ we don't do that we're not
going to start now stop asking it's not
going to happen you know this is some
ridiculous it's like sjw sang right okay
we'll have every
at the same level at some no that's not
gonna happen either you both got this
utopian ridiculous idea and but what's
worse is it's gonna necessitate
totalitarianism so make sure everyone
what marches in lockstep with what you
want done you're going to have to come
to talat Aryans and I'm really
comfortable with a free open and liberal
society so the answer is no to both of
them you know they can both go hang as
far as I'm concerned but the left just
needs to learn how to be funny again
frankly maybe it can do that now that
it's kind of lost all the power and
failed completely but I think that that
could be the saving grace that suddenly
they're gonna have to fight the power
again and maybe that will actually lead
liberalism to go back to his liberal
roots mr. Karle I could do easily
another hour with you back there I got a
run week we got a ton to do to get this
thing in order for next week but it was
a pleasure talking to you as always and
you know look some of these ideas are
getting out there that's the beautiful
thing and we just gotta keep pressing
again our job may be harder but if not
us you know who else is gonna do it well
that's the thing isn't you know if it's
not us then who if not now then when
but okay so I leave you with the last
things that the the people who are sort
of rational liberals they need an
identity they need some sort of like the
all truth has like like intersectional
social justice advocates have you know
that you need some kind of unifying
identity and it's not for yourselves
that you need this it's for other people
that you need this it's so the media can
say oh well like you know these these
like new liberals are doing something
you know or you know the the the alt
writer attacking the new liberals or
some nice is to is to get a sort of
political map in people's minds and
stake out your place in that map and so
people can recognize you as a force that
needs to be dealt with because I mean
between us we're coming on a million
subscribers and yet I don't feel like
we're getting anything done and I think
it's because people don't have a mental
map of us they don't really know where
to place us they're just kind of they're
just seeing individuals with large
audiences and thinking well it's just
one guy you know okay it's got a big
reach but you know I'll just ignore my
blocking or something and then he's gone
but if if we can find a label that we're
all generally happy to use that we can
push and like you called date on
hashtags and things like that then we
could actually start seeing us breaking
into the mainstream just like y'all
right that's exactly how the author I
did it that's exactly how these probably
have feminists did it to be honest I
should go and check in their history but
it's it's having a name and one thing
sorry I have a very quick last thing yes
everyone else gets hung up on the idea
of community and the sort parity of the
community drop it just drop it just drop
I mean communities are just something
people do there's a group people hanging
out together is a community it's no big
deal to call something a community and
okay well I'm happy to not have
collective blame as long as we don't
need collective guilt and responsibility
so that's fine you know if someone in
the community is bad then we say okay
that personal is a problem we're sorry
you know we we've disavowed him very
about it but now we're all you know it
it's not a big deal it's people people
act like you're signing up to an
organization you're getting a card and
you know now now you've got a whole list
of rules - fine no it's just do what the
alt-right did do what the feminists did
do what every social movements doing
online find an identity and push it so
you can at least and we can all Lisa
ground like four or five basic
principles like you know secularism
skepticism individual rights freedom of
expression and what democracy also in
asana the these sort of five puts who's
who's in disagreement with that you know
there are going to be millions of people
and this is what drives me crazy because
if we had some kind of identity we could
probably activate millions of people if
we could just get on you know get on TV
and be like no this is what we are this
what we stand for because you failed and
you're horrible so you know this is what
we want I think we would get a huge
flood of people coming to us because I
think most people are on our side well
you know what I started this by saying
that I don't know that we can win but I
think you just did a beautiful 2-minute
job of what our work should be for 2017
so I'm gonna keep working all I do that
it was a pleasure talking to you and
yeah I mean this is it this is it and I
know that people people hear you they
hear me they hear the other this other
gang of amorphous people that are coming
together and I think that that the next
the next wave of this is in our favor
and we're gonna
question so we'll do it again soon man